second débat tout de suite débat de
société vous le savez on choisit de le
décaler le plus souvent possible de
l'actualité prendre un peu de recul ça
fait du bien de temps en temps ce soir
gros plan sur cette loi qui permet de
changer beaucoup plus facilement de nom
de famille que contient le texte
pourquoi celui-ci style l'opposition de
certains explications avec flora sauvage
en 2021 plus de 3000 personnes ont
demandé à changer de nom une procédure
longue difficile qui n'aboutit pas
toujours avec cette nouvelle loi il
suffirait de remplir en mairie un simple
formulaire pour faire valoir ce nouveau
droit l'objectif de la proposition de
loi est de permettre à tout adulte qui
le souhaitent de prendre le nom de son
deuxième parent en l'ajoutant ou en le
substituant à son nom actuel cette loi
vise à répondre aussi à la souffrance
exprimée par de nombreux adultes femmes
ont été violées par
personne y est qui or ce nom quand même
ce désir de vouloir trouver une page sur
son passé
et si le fait de pouvoir porter le nom
sa mère permet d en cette démarche
depuis une loi de 2002 les parents la
possibilité de donner à leurs enfants à
la naissance le nom du père de la mère
ou les deux noms mais ces vingt
dernières années les pratiques ont peu
évolué
plus de 80% des enfants nés en 2010
cette porte toujours le nom de leur père
ce qui peut poser problème
lorsque les parents se séparent c'est
pour elle est la mère de famille qui
sont célibataires divorcés et qui
peuvent avoir des difficultés dans la
vie quotidienne
en ayant un enfant qui n'a pas le même
nom et qui
en attendant les reports doit se
justifier leur identité a justifié elles
sont les maires la proposition de loi
sera examinée par le sénat le 15 février
en cas de désaccord députés et sénateurs
se retrouveront en commission mixte
paritaire pour trouver un terrain
d'entente
et on débat autour de cette loi débat
société passionnant jacquet mais invité
patrick vignal bonsoir soit ce député
om de l'hérault c'est vous qui portez le
texte qui a été adopté par la commission
des lois de l'assemblée et qui viendra
donc devant les sénateurs la semaine
prochaine anne marie le pourhiet bonsoir
soir bienvenue vous êtes vice président
de l'association française de droit
constitutionnel et vous avez publié dans
le figaro une tribune opposée à ce texte
marie-odile mergnac bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes généalogistes élite risoux
publié généalogie remonter son arbre par
internet et en archives aux éditions
archives et culture j'accueille
également vincent couronne qui est
fondateur du média les surligneurs vous
traquer les contre-vérités juridique et
vous êtes partenaires de public sénat
ben soir vincent euros de de vous
retrouver encore une fois ce soir et
lætitia que page est resté à mes côtés
merci laetitia de participer vous aussi
à ce débat
quelques données sur l'évolution de la
loi sur sur les noms de famille avant
2005 nom du père obligatoire depuis le
1er janvier 2005 le nom du père ou le
nom de la mère ou le nom des deux
parents dans n'importe quel ordre loi du
17 mai 2013 en cas de désaccord entre
les parents l'enfant porte les noms
accolés par ordre alphabétique voilà
quelques éléments
me
récent on va dire pourquoi un nouveau
texte qu'est ce qui me semblait
important mais tout simplement parce que
je crois qu'il faut vivre avec le réel
et donc on avait beaucoup de remontées
notamment sur l'article beaucoup de
couples qui se séparent et souvent qu un
des deux parents qui n'avaient pas
transmis le nom avait des preuves
notamment les maires quand sp placé
aucun amener leurs enfants l'hôpital où
quand elle prenait l'avion donc
l'article on sait simplement une égalité
une équité faire en sorte en fait que ce
qui existait jusqu'à maintenant la femme
donne la vie et le père de son nom je
pense qu'il faut le faire évoluer et
dans l'article on ne prend rien à
personne c'est un nom d'usagé je précise
bien c'est au nom d' usage qui permet
dans la praticité quand les gens
divorcent quand ils se séparent de
pouvoir dire que la mère et la mère de
l'enfant tels se déplace je précise
aussi que vous avez des couples qui sont
séparés vous avez un premier compagnon
est un enfant un deuxième comprennent
qu'un enfant est l'intérêt d'une onde
usages c'est de souder la fratrie et on
est gamin quand ils sont à l'école il
porte le même nom d'usagé dont on ne
prend rien à personne c'est une loi qui
est gratuite qui dézingue encombre les
2000 ou 3000 demandes à la chancellerie
et qui encore une loi d'égalité mais il
dit mais il ya aussi la possibilité pour
un enfant même même plusieurs années
après de demander à changer de nom alors
la loi voilà et à ne plus porter le nom
éventuellement alors c'est la leçon
qu'elle attendait qu'on soit clair un
nom aujourd'hui on sait pas le matin non
c'est important non c'est une histoire
une belle histoire ou aussi une histoire
douloureuse on est d'accord donc quand
j'entends les gens qui m'explique que
c'est une loi du coeur moi j'invite les
gens quand je vois des gens en
souffrance buru des noms très compliqué
vous imaginez si vous appeliez thomas
abdeslam comment vous le porterez vous
imaginez si vous appelez thomas cocu ou
thomas fournir et où thomas hitler est
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on peut on peut
sauf que c'est entre 2 et s'éteint et
que c'est compliqué dont moi je ne veux
pas révolutionner le nom je veux pas
qu'on se lève matin que vous appeliez
thomas mann ou les simplifier les
démarches simplifie la démarche on avait
appris le nom d' usage et sur l'article
de la possibilité effectivement si vous
avez un os qui vous gêne que vous
puissiez de changer je précise à mes
auditions qu'on a auditionné des
généalogistes des sociologues des
professions d'identité on sait pas un
musée a changé nous avons donné le
moment la parole pour commencer pour
combien comprennent bien l'état d'esprit
dans lequel vous vous portez ce texte
anne marie le pourhiet vous êtes opposés
oui j'y suis opposé à d'appeaux de deux
raisons d'abord il ya une raison de
forme c'est que ça fait des lustres et
des lustres que le conseil d'état le
parlement tout le monde dénonce la façon
dont les oies sont faites en france
notamment les lois archi clientéliste
destinée à faire plaisir aux caprices
d'une une petite minorité et le tout
sans avoir mesuré l'impact et les
conséquences de tout ça à long terme
souvent sur des motivations extrêmement
superficielle voire erronés et et ça
c'est tout des rapports du conseil
d'état sur la malfaçon c'est la loi
vient d'abord
c'est l'archétype du texte vous savez
que depuis la révision de 2008 les
projets de loi gouvernementaux
doivent être accompagnées d'une étude
d'impact qui indiquent toutes les
conséquences possibles imaginables delà
de la loi sur tous les plans et de
surcroît les projets de loi d'un
gouvernement sont soumis pour avis au
conseil d'état bon avant comment ça
c'est vraiment une première raison est
une danse et la seconde à elle qu'il
fait nous hissions loi a pour but
d'éviter tout ça ni étude daouda dans la
rue sur la deuxième pour la qualité et
ça permet évidemment de faire passer des
textes archi clients release réponse
admet expliqué dd archiver liste d'abord
on a fait une étude sur plus de 3000
personnes on a plus de 50000 personnes
qui nous font appel encore tout à
l'heure dans un endroit pollen dit si
j'avais une personne qui me maquiller
qui m'expliqua elle aussi elle avait ce
problème qu'intéresse se déplacer elle
devait expliquer c'était la maman
comment on peut dire c'est une loi qui
les hantent ellis mais là il faut vivre
vous êtes en train de parler à une mère
de famille divorcée dont les enfants ne
portait pas le nom jamais je n'ai
rencontré les problèmes que vous pensez
de ces deux-là de l'affabulation et
comme avant et qu'on est en train de me
dis n'importe quel parent qui accompagne
en angleterre les autres noms des fuites
vous devez évidemment justifier votre
idole justin berg était enfin dans un
avion mais même s'il voire de 29 ce que
vous permettez que je puisse vous
réponds à les hisser par ayant trait à
chacun son troisième opus avait là
répond il faut vivre avec le réel la
société évoluée depuis longtemps le
problème du législateur et de langues de
la femme politique si les gens ne
retrouve pas le chemin des urnes c'est
parce que souvent on fait des lois qui
sont faits d'un des cabinets
ministériels qui sont pas adaptables 7
loin un elle est gratuite cette loi et
lens l1 à l'antenne de la souffrance
cette loi est le permet à chacun de
pouvoir résister sont avec vous et j'ai
bien lu votre article vous m'expliquer
en plus que c'est un courrier des coeurs
quand un gamin a été violée par un des
deux parents est qu'à la majorité il
faut changer le nom et enlever le nom du
bureau pour m'expliquer encore c'est de
l'affabulation madame et mais c'est vrai
qu'ils ont des moyens très bien mesquine
et riad re de la procédure actuelle qui
est fait justement pour contrôler
l'intérêt légitime mais madame c'est
entre 2 et 7 ans nous prenons un avocat
spécialisé il faut tourner sur une tige
si les services de monsieur mais ça
c'est grave
parce que
dans ce débat je vous je vous donnerai
la parole pour entendre votre second
argument tout à l'heure marie-odile
mergnac comment vous percevez vous tout
simplement ce ce texte qu'est ce qui
vous inspire ou qui travaillaient sur
notre généalogie depuis des années alors
il y a deux choses différentes la
première partie j'ai l'impression
qu'elle ne sert à rien puisque
enfin tout existe déjà le
le droit d' usage le nom d' usage depuis
85 en permanence on peut le faire
rajouter sur les documents
administratifs même pas les documents
d'état civil mais ça existe il est
possible de le faire et ça ne
solutionnera pas les problèmes éventuels
d'enfants qu'on apporte à l'aéroport que
ce soit le père où que ce soit la mère
il y à des divorces il y aura toujours
des situations difficiles et des gens
qui vont demander à ce qu'on prouve que
si on s'appelle hausse assez pour
l'article martin voilà bon et pour
l'article 2 il y à un effectivement la
capacité de changer n'ont été si voilà
il est possible de changer de nom depuis
depuis napoléon
avec effectivement des difficultés de de
délai actuellement parce que la quantité
de demandes a explosé on était à environ
1200 demandes dans les ados en 2005 je
crois on est passé à on a doublé presque
en 2015 il y avait eu des alertes
d'ailleurs sur les délais de
l'administration qui étaient passés de
une année on était passé déjà à deux ans
et puis là on a presque doublé on est à
trois cents
ça n'est pas normal effectivement dans
les cas de viol comme vous citez ou dans
des cas
de nom difficile à porter si on
s'appelle cocu cornichons et c'est ça
n'est pas facile
on peut avoir envie de changer de nom et
on peut trouver dommageable d'être
obligé avant d'entendre deux en quatre
ans 6 e b faut-il pour autant parce que
les délais sont trop longs dans
l'administration concernée faire
basculer la charge de tout cela vers les
36 mille employés d'état civil de des
36000 communes de france parce que ce
serait le seul problème parce qu'en fait
quand je vous écoute je comprends que ça
ne sert à rien enfin donc c'est le
joueur aurait changé non mais sinon rien
très bien mais quel est le problème si
la loi passe du coup
je le comprends pas quel est le problème
quel problème ça vous pose même si cette
loi passe
moi je ne raisonne pas dans ce drame la
danse et vous parlez de ligne et utilité
mais où moi je vois quelque chose la
motivation de la du collectif dont vous
faites le porte parole la motivation de
ce collectif dont le ministre la justice
se fait aussi le portent parfois se
forme la motivation c'est une
revendication de substitution de la
matroni à la patronymie c'est clair bon
c'est bon c'est personnes
supprimer la patronymie dominante le
patriarcat à travers la patronymie c'est
un combat donc ça c'est leur second
argument ça voilà
penser à ce qui est important pour
expliquer à madame cantine une
séparation un divorce un coq qui se
sépare un des deux parents qui n'a pas
donné le nom très souvent c'est comme ça
moi le premier j'ai donné le nom du père
a mis ensemble parce qu'ils sont nés il
ya très longtemps et qu'aujourd'hui
c'est à refaire et beaucoup on a
beaucoup de papas c'est pas que les
mamans et des gens qui me dit mais si
j'avais su j'aurais dit non parce que je
me suis séparé et je veux que la mère
qu'un jeu meuron mari soit la mer pour
le nom d' usage madame le problème
aujourd'hui c'est que l'un des deux
parents n'est pas d'accord pour faire
rajouter le nom d' usage ça veut dire
qu'on met de la souffrance chez les
enfants et ça veut dire qu'on a toujours
cette séparation moi c'est pas une loi
pour les adultes c'est une loi de
praticité pour les enfants après madame
je suis désolé de vous le dire mais
comment vous pouvez expliquer je suis le
porte parole d'un collectif
vous savez vous reconnaîtrez danser dans
votre exposé dans madame j'ai demandé
que j'explique différement vous savez la
différence qu'on a tous les deux c'est
que moi je suis constamment dans la rue
je suis pas d'adjoint de cabinet être
toujours le droit le droit il voulut
doit évoluer avec la société pour
connaître les réponses il faut vivre
aussi les questions et si on passe le
temps à rester dans nos bureaux à
attendre voilà société comme elle évolué
et c'est pareil pour le mariage pour
tous parce que je vous étiez contre moi
je suis pour de l'amour moi je suis
qu'au bord les gens ils puissent
s'entendre alors on va on va compter
avec des battes et je voudrais entendre
vincent couronne qui nous écoute depuis
depuis le début de ce débat peut être un
voilà vous êtes là vous vous traquer les
contre-vérités juridiques notamment dans
cette campagne présidentielle mais c'est
passionnant aussi sur ceux ces enjeux de
voilà de mutation de notre société
peut-être qu'il faut commencer par
rappeler le les fonctions principales du
nom de notre droit tout simplement
vincent
bon déjà je hais tandis que je suis très
courageux je ne vais pas prendre partie
dans ce débat là
est donc resté très très neutre mais le
nom en fait tout simplement il a une
fonction double endroit c'est d'abord
identifier une personne simplement c'est
une fonction qu'on dit d'ordre public
mais elle a une autre fonction c'est un
droit subjectif qui permet à la personne
de défendre son nom par exemple son
honneur on va défendre l'honneur
lorsqu'il est salie de l'otan sur
l'honneur de son nom y compris
d'ailleurs après sa mort ou encore en
interdisant à d'autres personnes de
l'usure p c'est ce qui explique que
toute personne doit avoir un nom et ce à
la règle selon laquelle toute personne
doit avoir un nom et qu'elles utilisent
non qui est inscrit à l'état civil ça
vient d'une loi du 6 fructidor en 2
c'était pendant la révolution française
7794 pourrait plus précis et qui dit
donc on doit forcément porter le nom qui
est dans l'état civil et qu'on ne peut
plus en changer sauf quelques exceptions
et des exceptions qui vont se multiplier
au cours des années jusqu'à jusqu'à 7
cette nouvelle loi cette proposition de
loi donc ça c'est ce qu'on appelle le
principe de l'immutabilité secure les
quels sont les exceptions justement
puisqu'on a commencé à l'évoquer mais
précisément à 100 alors ce principe de
10 mutabilité effectivement sur lequel
on change pas le nom ils datent même
d'encore un peu plus loin c'est à dire
même beaucoup plus loin c'est le lady
d'amboise en 1555 mais je vais pas faire
toute l'histoire je vais vous épargner
sa les exceptions c'est quoi depuis 1993
93 si votre nom est grossier où il est
péjoratif par exemple
eh bien vous ne pouvez pas enfin vous
avez la possibilité de le changer si le
nom porté celui d'un parent qui a été
condamnée par exemple pour des faits
graves ou alors un parent qui a
brutalement abandonné l'enfant
là on peut aussi demander à changer de
nom bien au delà de 7 ans en fait toute
la vie contrairement à ce que j'ai
entendu tout à l'heure sur le plateau si
une personne aussi vu franciser son nom
ça arrive souvent après une
naturalisation c'est aussi possible et
puis il ya encore une autre une autre
exception d'autres possibilités c'est
lorsque le nom d' usage que vous portez
eh bien il est utilisé depuis au moins
trois générations est bien là vous avez
la possibilité là aussi de le faire
changer l'état civil donc depuis s'était
dit d'amboise 2555 la société a changé
et les non apparemment aussi alors
laetitia merci vincent je reviens vers
vous tout à l'heure laetitia ce texte
qui concerne il concerne pas seulement
mais concerne particulièrement les
familles monoparentales et c'est alors
si on essaie de
de prendre un peu d'eau résidentiels à
côté c'est ça qu'est ce que c'est un
thème qui rentre un peu dans cette
campagne prudence je me suis intéressé
thomas parce qu'effectivement on se dit
que c'est les familles monoparentales
qui sont les plus concernés directement
par cette loi mais c'est un sujet la
famille monoparentale qui frappent à la
porte des politiques depuis deux
campagnes déjà 2012 toutes les
associations ont fait le tour des
candidats emportant sept revendications
de reconnaissance de la famille
monoparentale 2010 est un nouveau et
puis bon finalement ça n'a pas pris le
débat n'a pas vraiment porté sur cette
nouvelle réalité sociologique et la
l'insee dernier rapport en septembre
nous indique qu'une famille sur quatre
est monoparentale en france aujourd'hui
une famille sur quatre donc on comprend
bien l'importance aujourd'hui de
considérer cette nouvelle réalité
sociale et donc face à cette réalité qui
est démographique et sociologique les
candidats commencent à réagir oui enfin
de ceux qui excusent pas vraiment au
portillon comme on dit c'est encore
timide mais oui il y a deux candidates
valérie pécresse et marine le pen qui
font des propositions sur le sujet je
vous propose de les écouter j'ai aussi
la volonté d'augmenter pas de refondre
toute la politique familiale en mettant
en place une allocation familiales dès
le premier enfant parce que vous le
savez dans le monde de l'après qu'ovide
pour lequel je porte un projet je veux
redonner de l'espoir attention
particulière aussi
pour les nombreuses familles françaises
monoparentales
pour lesquelles je doublerai
l'allocation de soutien familial
vous avez
élevé seules des enfants
situation beaucoup plus souvent subie
que choisie est un poids financier et
psychologique loup
dont deux candidates on va pas faire de
distinction de genre mais voilà deux
candidates pour se sait ces mesures
alors pour marine le pen il s'agit en
fait de doubler la location de 116 euros
par an elle serait à 230 euros par an
mais conditionnée à vos revenus et pour
valérie pécresse c'est 900 euros par an
75 euros par mois et sans condition de
ressources dès le premier enfant c'est
quand même pas non plus révolutionnaire
comme mesurée à gauche pour le moment
les candidats qui avec la sociologie
électorale devrait être davantage
concernés par cette question ça reste
très timide voire totalement silencieux
sujet n'est pas central patrimonial est
ce que ce texte il s'adresse
prioritairement aux familles
monoparentales mais ça fait partie je
pense que la notion de couple est voulu
et vous l'avez dit madame
malheureusement une famille sur quatre
effectué ma est séparé je veux dire que
je le vois bien mauvais les jeunes
générations il ya une métamorphose c'est
à dire que ce qui a existé par le passé
encore une fois on nie pas c'est pas
remplacer le patron par l'one matronyme
sert au maire de l'égalité les hommes et
les femmes sont égaux en droits et donc
si vous voulez derrière ce texte là
j'entends aussi - les interpellations
des sénateurs en fait être très clair
quelqu'un qui est délinquant ou qui ont
des les cantines ainsi change pas de nom
il oublie pas j'ai avec moi la
fédération nationale des généalogistes
que nous avons reçu encore ce matin j'ai
changé qu'une jeune generis des droits
successoraux qui me disait dans la
mesure où si on substitue le nom et que
l'autre nom et dans l'état s'il est dans
les tables ça ne pose aucun problème
nous sommes au troisième millénaire par
contre après cette loi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est que les généalogistes
puissent avoir accès
dématérialisée sur les états civils
c'est ça faire une loi c'est pour ça
madame que je suis désolé vous êtes
certainement brillante endroit mais
ouvrez les yeux regardez ce que je ne
suis fait mal je suis une famille en eau
par n'a donc je ne suis madame lemieux h
sérieux monsieur juste mer et vous
n'aurez plus où dit elle appuie des
travaux si on avait suivi mais vous
allez non pas le nom de leurs enfants
c'est faux nico ou pas dire voilà
matière
vous entendez ce que vous pouvez
m'expliquer une mère qui porte le nom de
son enfant vous croyez qu'elle va à
l'aéroport le mettre dans un avion
change justifier sans présenter une
carte d'identité et mais tout le monde
doit justifier qu'un enfant et le cerf
la pose pas de problème puisque mal même
nom mais oui mais je n'en ai pas écrit
sur le visage
donnez votre carte d'identité et que les
deux noms sont différents c'est là que
ce soit une présidente et ouais ouais on
compte une copie du livret de famille
qu'elle ait problème et non de copies
des mémoires sachant bazar mais non
madame ça ne change rien du un budget de
mauvaise foi comme argument des de
mauvaise foi la lassitude est gratuite
les ressorts s'agit d'éliminer mais non
et paternel si bien sûr on en est c'est
pas de l'oie féministe c'est le père
mais comme en danger vous est-ce que
vous mesurer l'impact de ce que vous
faites alors voyez madame on va aller
plus loin on va aller derrière la loi
moi j'ai reçu l'association sos papa
aussi qu'ils ont proposé le ppl est ce
que gmail pour la plage du père
proposition proposition excusez-moi
proposition de loi pour retrouver leur
place vous savez vous savez le vrai
débat notre société c'est que dès qu'il
ya un problème les gens sont de suite 22
bouée dos à dos après cette loi qui
n'empêche rien à personne qui est
gratuit qui coûte rien à vos impôts qui
enlèvent des souffrances qui met de
l'égalité il faut aussi s'occuper avec
sos papa aston malheureusement souvent
alors 80 % des femmes qui ont la garde
mon retrait du a même temps de l'égalité
est voulue par et d'affabulations
les et revenir sur le fait que le nom
sert d'identification donc le risque
c'est effectivement si on a juste un
formulaire cerfa si ça n'est pas reporté
correctement sur
l'état civil on peut se retrouver avec
ce qui a valu la loi de 1794 évoqué tout
à l'heure
elle avait été créée pour éviter les
yeux les usurpations que je vais y
arriver d'identité et
les fraudes en 1793 un an plus tôt on
avait dit chacun est libre de choisir le
nom qu'il veut et il a fallu faire
machine arrière très vite parce qu'il y
avait énormément d'abus donc il faut
absolument
que ceux ci soient abordées jeu j'ai
travaillé avec myriam provence qui fait
beaucoup de dossiers de changement de
nom pour des particuliers maintenant
elle à 50% de ces demandes qui émanent
de gens d'un petit peu tous les âges et
effectivement parfois pour motif
affectif pour revenir pour qu'ils se
retrouvent dans ce qui est permis aux
enfants nés après 2005 c'est à dire
avoir le choix entre nom du père nom de
la mère ou les deux
l'inconvénient c'est que si ils ont 50
ou 60 ans il y a des enfants parfois des
petits enfants ça transforme les noms au
sein de la famille et peut-être qu'il
faudrait limiter cette loi à une tranche
d'âge 18 20 20 ans alors joris est
simple elle doit arriver au sénat
maintenant et je propose à quentin a
calmé de nous rejoindre rebond soir
bonsoir quentin l arrivée au sénat la
dent dans quelques jours avec un examen
qui s'annonce peut-être un peu compliqué
pourquoi oui on voit que c'est un sujet
qui a déclenché les passions on pense ça
va être la même chose effectivement au
sénat pour être très précis il est
examiné en commission des lois deux
mains thomas et en séance la semaine
prochaine ce sera donc le 15 janvier on
a déjà vu ce que la sellerie le 15
février mais on ne va juste que les
sénateurs vont proposer comme
modifications sert qu'on a pu lire la
liste des amendements qu'ils vont
proposer pour modifier le texte déjà
adopté par l'assemblée nationale on l'a
compris aussi dans le discours monsieur
vignal par exemple on voit effectivement
c'est tellement et qui s'affiche avec
une vingtaine de sénateurs qui veulent
complètement supprimée la mesure phare
du texte avec cette simplification de la
procédure par un formulaire cerfa ces
sénateurs de la droite et du centre ils
disent que ce texte ans à faire du port
du nom de famille un droit individus que
cet article pourrait offert que vous
pouvez la porte à des abus ils disent
que le changement de nom ne saurait se
fonder sur le simple mouvement d'humeur
c'est l'argument des sénateurs de la
droite et du centre donc ses 25
sénateurs qui vont proposer la
suppression et on a même vu le président
du groupe l air au sénat bruno
retailleau parlé il ya quelques semaines
de changement qui participeraient je
cite à la déconstruction de la société
de la famille de cette volonté des
minorités d'imposer leur loi c'est dans
l'opinion c'était le 19 janvier dernier
on verra si donc il ya une majorité de
sénateurs pour supprimer cette mesure
phare du texte mais on a vu aussi la
rapporteure l ère du texte qu'elle a
plutôt cherché à trouver une position
d'entre d'eux pour un peu réunir
l'ensemble de la commission avec une
simplification en supprimant l'exigence
de justification d'un intérêt légitime
pour eh bien eh bien cette demande de
changement de nom par décrire ce qu'est
le cas aujourd'hui en clair plus besoin
plus besoin de justifier comme c'est le
cas aujourd'hui
la demande en revanche elle ne veut pas
d'un simple formulaire il faudrait bien
passer par un décret du ministère de la
justice la rapporteure et qui que cette
disposition n'a pas été suffisamment
pensés tant sur le plan des conséquences
qu'elle entraîne pour les enfants
mineurs en ce qui concerne et bien le
changement de nom qui s'appliquait
automatiquement en 4 et bien d'âge
inférieure à 13 ans enfin la rapporteure
est très critique sur le timing monsieur
vignal une proposition de loi venue de
l'assemblée nationale avec une procédure
accélérée c'est à dire une seule lecture
par chambre et non pas 2 avec cette
navette regardez ce qu'écrit marie
mercier les conditions de l'examen de
cette proposition de loi en procédure
accélérée ne permettent pas de prendre
la mesure de l'ampleur des demandes on
sait pas combien il y en aura et quel
pourrait être l'impact sur les
administrations concernées on parle donc
des mairies en france les sénateurs et
qui ont d'ailleurs dénoncé dans leur
rapport ces délais très courts pour les
changements si important monsieur vinel
merci beaucoup quentin pour pour ces
détails je reprends la la citation
du chef de file des sénateurs et l'air
bruno retailleau quand il dit c'est
quand même serudin cette fois participe
à la déconstruction de la famille et
notre société mais à coup sûr dès que le
sénateur retailleau a dû voir comment
fonctionnent nos familles aujourd'hui
premier point moi j'ai envie de faire
confiance aux français je me suis posé
la question quand on parle de changement
de nom je me dis oh nadeau il a 20 ans
votre enfant peut-être malaise il se
réveille matin ils étaient contents et
les voilà à la plage voilà en disant
alors dix ans elle a le temps mais avec
la loi gignac ça va aller vite elle se
dispute à et maman elle le dit je vais
aller chez papa et je prend le nom de
papa et ça marche pas comme ça nous par
contre et c'est aussi la réfection des
sénateurs c'est pour changer de nom
est-ce que c'est simple on va la mairie
l'état civil on dit je m'appelais hughes
et non plus génial ou est ce que
peut-être et c'est l'idée de faire
évoluer avec ce des sénateurs qui ont
envie de jouer le jeu comment va le
border est ce que on a un délai de 15
jours un mois pour réfléchir vous savez
que c'est qu'une fois est-ce qu'il faut
peut-être publié au journal officiel et
rajouter une petite contrainte
financière mais comment on peut parler
de mouvement d'humeur ou déconstruire la
famille je crois qu'aujourd'hui la
famille elle a évolué et nous les hommes
politiques doivent évoluer aussi sinon
être à contre sens de l'évolution de la
société parce que la société évolue et
on peut se marier deux femmes dont on a
eu que deux ans peuvent se marier et
surtout ils ont le droit et ils peuvent
s'aimer c'est pour sa 7e loin elle est
gratuite elle ne veut rien parce que je
suis ni pour le nom d' usage madame
aujourd'hui il faut que notre parent
soit d'accord on en compte dans la
chancellerie là c'est quoi l'histoire
c'est que si demain vous voulez rajouter
votre nom d'usager vous pouvez leur
ajouté si l'autre parent n'est pas
d'accord c'est lui qui peut déposer la
chancellerie et expliquer pourquoi il
n'est pas d'accord donc j'ai rien pris a
personne au bon un soutien
ministre de la justice il expliqué
pourquoi il soutient ce texte aux
journalistes du magazine elle c'était le
19 décembre dernier en écoute eric
dupond moretti
ce texte est pour moi enthousiasmant et
ailleurs je voudrais mais vous savez
vous dire que dans mon histoire
personnelle
ce texte
résonne bien sûr puisque je le dis je
veux le dire ici c'est pas c'est pas du
déballage
mon père est mort quand j'étais petit
garçon c'est d'ailleurs un exemple qui
est illustratif de ce que peut permettre
ce texte
j'ai été élevé seule par ma mère
je suis trouvé qu'elle avait fait bien
des sacrifices et j'ai souhaité à coller
à mon nom son nom elle
pour ne rien vous cacher les choses ont
été facilités parce que j'étais connu
sous le nom d'eric dupond-moretti
c'était mon nom d'usager tu es un avocat
connu sous ce nom yves dupont moretti et
vidic évidemment pour des anonymes c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué dans la
proposition de loi et c'est pas rajouter
ses substituts mais
il s'agit de permettre à une mère de
changer le nom d' usage de substituer
son nom à celui du père sans le
consentement du père sauf alors dans
l'hypothèse où l'enfant est mineure elle
devra en informer en temps utile qu'elle
lui change donc son nom d'usager keil
substitut le sien à celui du père et
alors là le père ci n'est pas d'accord
il faudra qu'il saisisse le juge aux
affaires familiales qui l'a vérifiera
l'intérêt de l'enfant tiens le contrôle
juridictionnelle réapparait quand il
allie de l'opposition du père est donc
l'intérêt de l'enfant ne saura donc pris
en compte que s'il ya opposition aux
positions du père pris en compte de
manière objective j'entends un on est
dans une affaire l'état civil c'est de
l'ordre public c'est bien pour ça que je
réagis en constitutionnaliste je suis
pas civilistes mais c'est depuis
toujours une affaire d'ordre public
c'est celle attributions régaliennes par
excellence et l'état civil dont on fait
pas ce qu'on veut et on ne transforme
pas l'état civil en self service en
supermarché où chacun vient ben
finalement j'aime plus mon mari je veux
plus entendre parler de son nom ça
m'énerve de voir mon enfant porté son
nom et puis allez hop je le dis oui le
père comme ça non ça ne on ne fait pas
ces choses là et le législateur civile
ne doit pas justement accompagner ses
pulsions et doit bien raisonner en
visant l'intérêt de la société
dans l'ensemble et non pas en répondant
à des cas de misérabilisme individuel le
garde des sceaux qui raconte sa petite
histoire nunucherie personnel non c'est
pourquoi on faisait ça mais non mais
c'est pas comme ça pour ma part c'est
pas comme ça qu'on légifère
oui mais l'émotion
personnel et est alors si vous voulez
qu'on mettre le nom de sa mère on est
passé à voir l'émotion ça c'est par ici
avez vous dire sans arrêt on ne retire
rien non madame merci quand on substitue
le nom de la mère celui du père on
retient bien quelque chose
page 1 milliard une partie de votre
questionnement et je vais essayer d'être
plus succincts comme sur l'article 1 les
grosses demandes souvent c'est de
rajouter le nom d' usage pour la
praticité la substitution c'est en cas
de problème grave notamment abus sexuels
ces bonnes des deux marins sur l'article
2 c'est vraiment une substitution à m'en
donner à gardant le nom dans les tables
et dans l'état civil pour éviter la
fraude et c'est surtout sur des cas
graves moi j'ai envie de faire confiance
aux gens alors vous allez me dire c'est
qu'un témoignage mais c'est des millions
de témoignages j'ai des témoignages où
la personne a été abusée sexuellement
par un des deux parents est âge adulte
mais à quarante à cinquante ans ça fait
20 ans qu'elle un sac à dos et qu'elle
veut poser le nom de son bourreau celle
là c'est le valletta civile j'ai pas
besoin que le pass à la chancellerie
c'est par dizaines que le prennnent
avocat spécialisé qu'elles attendent
entre 2 et 7 ans parce qu'elle a une
souffrance elle un sac à dos c'est pour
cela cette loi s'adresse madame je vois
pas quelqu'un se lever un matin ghedir
deux coups thèmes plus tempère 20 levé
tournon je veux faire confiance aux
français je pense que c'est important et
j'entends mais moi cette loi elle est au
sénat les sénateurs aujourd'hui ils
écoutent ce soir notre émission et s'ils
veulent bord d un peu plus ça sera
l'objet d'une cmp c'est comme ça qu'on
filme de loin et c'est pas un expliquant
qu'on a failli hier commission
vous ne riez pas près de changer à voir
qu'est ce qui se passe est pourquoi
c'était si l'on au ministère de la
justice
le garde des sceaux ne peut pas vérifier
comment fonctionnent ces services vous
me dites du 2 à 7 ans j'ai plutôt vu
deux ans maximum dans les
caisses qui se passe aujourd'hui vincent
pour celles et ceux dont la demande de
changement de nom est refusée parce
qu'il ya il ya eu vous l'avez évoqué
tout à l'heure en 2001 j'ai vu 4293
demande enregistré 44 % des requêtes
seulement ont été acceptés qu'est-ce qui
se passe en cas de refus il ya des
recours on peut aller jusqu où jusqu'à
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
comment ça se passe
oui les dégâts des eaux court bien
évidemment parce qu'on est dans un état
de droit donc on peut faire appel au
juge un et la loi en débat actuellement
elle elle permet aussi de faire appel au
juge en cas de désaccord là on peut
aller jusqu'à ça peut aller
effectivement comme vous dites jusqu'à
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
il faut dire que la france elle est
assez protégé sur ce cas là parce que
elle a souvent été précurseur en fait
sur la question du nom et de l'égalité
entre le père et la mère dans la
transmission du nom en 1901
4,85 elle permet à la mère de
transmettre son nom et en 94 c'est la
suisse qui s'est fait condamnée par la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
parce qu'elle ne le permettait pas en
2002 la france va un peu plus loin et
elle permet à la mère le transmette son
usage est en 2014 c'est l'italie qui se
fait condamner par la cdh parce qu'elle
ne le permettait pas donc en réalité en
france on lit tu as est à l'abri d'une
condamnation à cod h sur ces questions
là ça ça fonctionne pas trop trop mal
merci vincent un dernier mot marie-odile
mergnac est ce que vous craignez on
l'évoqué c'était en filigrane dans tous
vos débats que les enfants soient un peu
écartelée à un moment en
qu'on leur demande de choisir entre le
nom du père de la mère avec cette très
franc oui oui à la majorité on n'a pas
encore pour le moment les les
conséquences visibles de la loi de
2001 2002 qui s'est appliqué à partir de
2005 c'est à dire les enfants ont
éventuellement le nom des deux parents
mais ne peuvent en transmettre qu'un on
ne peut pas avoir quatre noms lui non et
c'est à chaque génération donc il va y
avoir ce choix qui ne se pratiquait pas
autrefois dans les pays comme l'espagne
qui avait si un système double puisqu'on
ne transmettait systématiquement que le
même c'était le nom du père encore et
choisissent alors c'est ça on choisit
quel nom traces mais là on doit choisir
quel nom transmet c'est à dire qu'à la
majorité ou au moment du mariage ou au
moment de la naissance d'un enfant un
adulte là qui va porter deux noms les
noms de ses deux parents devra choisir
et non transmettre qu'un seul et son
choix s'appliquera pour tous les enfants
suivant tous les enfants à naître pour
une même fratrie et donc le risque c'est
que
la maman disent tu transmets le nom de
ton papa tu le lait mieux que moi et
[Musique]
le papa va faire pareil les beaux
parents les grands parents vont s'en
mêler on n'a pas encore vu l'impact de
psychologique sur les enfants et bien il
faudra refaire cela dans quelques temps
on va dire que moi ou dans quelques
années merci beaucoup merci à tous d'y
avoir participé et de vous être écouté
les uns les autres même si vous n'étiez
pas d'accord marie-odile mergnac
j'appelle le titre de votre livre
généalogie remonter son arbre par
internet et en archives c'est aux
éditions archives et culture merci
vincent pour votre expertise comme à
chaque fois à demain merci à toutes et à
tous de votre fidélité
votre rendez vous politique de au matin
avec
regarde nancy nice et patrick mennucci
qui est membre de l'équipe de campagne
donne hidalgo salut belle soirée
[Musique]